this week's n a last chance qualifier
for valerian champions has been
postponed until further notice it's been
a hell of a week
from whole regions being forced to
forfeit their spots from tech and covet
issues all within 24 hours the lcq has
become everyone's worst nightmare
let's talk about it
[Music]
hey everyone before we get into the
video i just want to let you know that
we partnered with bose to help create
their newest rule the quiet social
segments which follows key storylines at
worlds and they send over these amazing
headphones so check it out in the link
below
after masters berlin the entire valorant
community including myself looked
forward to the last chance qualifier to
see who was gonna make it to champions
this week would have been the absolute
last chance for these teams to make it
to champions there are no second chances
after this tournament it is literally do
or die however it looks like these teams
will have to wait to compete as rei has
announced they are postponing the entire
lcq so how did we get here and what went
wrong the first surprise came before the
lcq the region of oceana would not be
able to compete and would be forfeiting
from the competition
due to travel issues the official
statement from riot read as follows due
to coven 19 regulations travel
documentation issues and additional
complex factors we could not ensure that
these teams could travel compete in the
event and return home in a reasonable
time frame thus order and chiefs will
not be attending lcq
dicserto reported that some oce players
had already begun to travel when the
news hit and that riot had not enough
time to secure the players travel to
compete teams were approached about
flights to north america ahead of the
oce championship giving riot around six
to eight weeks to process it all even if
they hadn't qualified
this is a shorter timeframe than oceanic
orc peace forgiven for the league of
legends world championship with teams
filing paperwork three months before
qualifying but in the week leading up to
the cancellation riot administrators had
not managed to secure exit exemptions
for australian players despite order and
chiefs telling riot about their
importance
so the n a and o c e l c q became the n
a l c q but the issues don't stop there
the teams that were not forced to
forfeit their spots arrived in la for
the lcq and then
the tech issues began the last chance
qualifiers were expected to be an
in-person lan event but the thing is
it's not land in fact they're using the
regular northern california servers yes
the ones us plebs use so the players
they're in person they're playing on
this incredible stage but
they're playing using online servers
being online obviously gives them a huge
competitive disadvantage and frankly it
is game changing you and i will never
experience xero ping because we're not
going to be pros nor we like wired into
the servers these pros are competing
with each other to find out who is the
most deserving to fly to berlin for
champions it can be kind of hard to tell
who deserves that spot when you don't
have the most precise accurate gameplay
100 thieves player nitro tweeted in
response to a question about why they
were playing online they don't have land
servers for whatever reason not the end
of the world just interesting and we're
spiking sometimes drones not coming out
the first time i threw a jet smoke and
it threw two at once etc his teammate
asana replied to another tweet by ethan
saying that the inter team comms
included lagging can't flash and also
lagging the technical issues became
incredibly obvious during the game
between xs and luminosity gaming as yay
put it so eloquently on twitter
lmao what is happening on the nalcq
stream
and 12 bullets to work with he doesn't
have the spike either so he's gonna have
to either land the frags with 13 seconds
left or gets it
10 seconds left
god
i'm holding my breath here doug i'm
holding my breath there it is we're able
to actually see that round play out i
wasn't the only one taken aback by that
moment take a look at shazam's reaction
[Music]
that's [ __ ] horrible dude
that's [ __ ] horrible no i've been
watching the lcq and there have been
lots of tech and gear checks it's
slowing down games stalling matches
it's not fun for the viewer nor the
players corroborating the tech issues
gen g player temperature also tweeted
that after a tech check his keyboard was
messed up you might have thought there
would have been a ruling to replay that
round or even that map with all the tech
issues it would make sense that
considering that one round showed
something was not up to par but no such
ruling was made all games continued as
if nothing had happened i know there
wasn't even a discussion about it i
think they um
second after third and up i don't
remember which but they ended up doing
like a tech polish to try and fix it i
think
and i think it kept happening still i
feel for these players immensely i
cannot imagine the stress and pressure
you must feel playing in the last chance
qualifier to make it to champions and
then you're playing under these
conditions where you're unable to play
at your best and you did not expect to
play under to be blunt it is absolutely
unacceptable just that one clip shows
that round could have changed everything
that 1v2 could have been clutch but
instead the round was lost and things
were affected like your econ your mental
you name it rapto said in that same
interview that that specific lagging
came at a crucial moment ride games has
responded to the negative reactions
regarding the first day tech issues with
the following statement since we started
planning the nalcq earlier this year our
goal was to have a lan event given
stricter protocols for in-person events
who felt it was best in the interest of
all to shift to a remote server should
any players need to be quarantined this
would allow for teams to continue to
compete and not bring a sub or be forced
to forfeit we recognize this virtual
server is not the same as playing on lan
however we are diligently working on
improving the remote server experience
throughout the competition hiko told us
in an interview that they expected it to
be lan and not online i think we all
expected it not to be
online servers i think if we would have
known you know when we would have
we were talking about this tournament in
general that it was online servers we
probably would have caused a bigger
stink than we
did even just today on twitter
um
but yeah i think they told us that the
day we landed that
we would be playing
in online servers
because of whatever whatever the reason
is
i know that me and a couple of my
teammates were unhappy and our coach
actually reached out to the staff and
said hey this is not cool it's not okay
we need to fix this and
for
the reasons they gave us
that unfortunately didn't really matter
it should also be noted that the
broadcast was 11 hours long there were
three series and at most that should
have taken nine hours a proto who was
the cipher in that clip i showed you had
this to say about the issues during the
1v2
was winning that i'm very certain i was
going to win that
and i just i double caged i started
walking stairs and there's this ghost in
front of me and i just started shooting
it and
then i realized the server just dc
um
and then
everyone might spawn back in and these
two guys are just like to my left both
looking everywhere and they just killed
me
regardless of whether it was expected or
not became obvious at the tech issues
the players were facing became worse as
the day dragged on but the problems
don't stop there
buckle up for this one to start on
october 6 exit def tweets that he is
flying to la for the lcq then on october
10th he tweets that's been a secret but
he tested positive for kovid has since
tested negative and will be able to play
with his team then on october 12th after
that match he tweets that la county has
reached out to him and has asked him to
isolate even after a negative pcr test
something similar happened to shanks who
plays for ryze they flew to la on the
seventh and tested positive on the
eighth he deleted that tweet then he
tested negative on the 11th and then was
asked to isolate on the 12th finally he
tested negative again on the 13th the
day he was supposed to play on stage
with his team october 13th was supposed
to be the day of the match between phase
and rise then we got news from the
players that things were not going
according to plan players were testing
positive being asked to quarantine and
play from their own soul hotel rooms and
whole teams were asked to leave the
stage and play the games from their own
pcs at their home bases
it's a lot derek from rice said that
october 13th nothing against fey's boys
but it's kind of
none of them are playing on stage and
are able to go home on nasa pcs while
only four members arise or on stage on
lcs pcs only two phase members tested
positive shanks then tweeted the day of
his match in conclusion forced to play
and they at home all good time to lock
in to simplify this
two phase members tested positive and
the entire phase team was asked to play
from their home base ryze would be
playing on stage with four members while
shanks played the game from his hotel
room people were upset because the lcs
pcs were just not up to professional
standards and faze being able to go home
and play in their own pcs would give
them a huge technical advantage faze
rockets ended up streaming on the 13th
and said riot has been nothing but great
either the fault lies with la county
protocols i don't think it's anything to
do with
like riot's thing i think it's all l.a
county protocols right it's been like
nothing but understanding and like i've
shown like really good hospitality to be
honest i don't want anything negative to
go like on there and at all because like
it's not been
like i promise i'm not just saying that
to say that like they haven't done
anything wrong they've been like really
nice to us in my opinion so
very it's very like it's very weird i
was very surprised with how hospital
they've been so
did the same thing happen at dapper
before berlin why did that work out i
think it's due to uh the country's
guidelines
right like iceland i think it was
iceland not berlin that guy
faced baby bay echoed that in a tweet
saying i'm fully vaccinated i tested
negative multiple days in a row i tested
positive and then negative 10 minutes
after can't play on stage and have to
quarantine ellie covert rules are
different bro shanks also streamed after
all this and
um
hey guys this is where i'm going to be
playing the lan event from on land by
the way
this one's for one leaf
on october 14th riot officially
announced that they will be postponing
the entire tournament until further
notice and it would return as a remote
online event
the statement read as follows given the
events of the past few days out of an
abundance of caution and with the health
and safety of all being in the top of
mind we have made the difficult decision
to postpone the event until further
notice
player and staff safety remain our top
concern as we navigate the current
situation we share the community's
disappointment and we are working
diligently to transition the lcq to an
online event similar to vct matches
earlier this year and resume play as
soon as possible to send our final team
to valorem champions
except bcj tweeted in response to all of
the discourse on twitter about the event
that this was not riot's fault the event
has actually been going okay all things
considered to be cj's point about false
positives i like to compare it to a
similar situation that happened
before iceland before masters 2. dapper
from sentinels tested positive for covid
since he had recovered about a month
earlier dapper tweeted the following the
reason we were all stressed last week
going into iceland was because a week
before we had to leave i took a positive
covet test the reason it was positive
was because i had it a month prior and
dead cells stayed in my body since then
i tested negative three times in a row
as we all know dapper went to iceland
with his team and won the entire event
how the [ __ ] are all these people at lcq
testing positive what you guys doing at
the hotel don't read the replies to that
tweet don't do it i did it you don't
have to as to what has happened so far
this event has literally been tragic on
so many different levels it's been
incredibly disappointing to see the lcq
halted in this way i'm sure the ltq will
continue soon enough and will be able to
watch all the matches but this still
sucks for literally everyone involved
competitors expressed their
disappointment for not being able to
play on stage at all it must be
incredibly upsetting to have an
opportunity like the lcq turnout like
this all in all riot is making the call
to postpone the event for the health and
safety of everyone whether or not the
tests were false no unnecessary risks
should be taken that would put anyone
there in danger of getting sick when the
event does return let's just hope that
the tournament can go ahead without all
these recent difficulties it is the very
least these players deserve
also to the one person who said it
looked like faze baby bae what are you
talking about can we do a side by side
is it possible do i look like faze baby
bae i don't think i do like great he's
like he's a handsome guy don't get me
wrong but like i don't look like this
why are you saying no you
don't talk